hi today uh
i'm going to go over the 13 joe carter
again
but uh different teachers
from different areas following
cytoscency
will have done uh different stages
different thoughts as he progressed and
developed
got older things changed your
views changed but
he said while i was under his
instruction that
the thirteen joe carter was the missing
suburbs
of from what the twenty joe suburis
have there's some different movements in
there
so it's a bit contradictory
when doing the carter you should think
of doing them as suburu as he told us
and yet when you're doing a free-flowing
carter
you have to realize that
inwardly you have the strength and power
to block strike
but you don't have enough time to stay
around long enough to show it
and you'll see many different teachers
demonstrating this around the
world as we now seem to be online
doing a lot teachers will tell you
different things this is my take on it
i followed him from 1983 to two
to the time he died but
pretty much the last time was uh in the
early 2000s
uh just before he died was
my last physical period with him
okay so so they might differ things to
what other people tell you but this is
my take on it
i'm going to keep going over the same
basics as always
don't look down it's immature
you don't need to look down
don't turn the body when you go to get
your
jo soften the knees stretch the arm out
soften the knees stretch the arm out
don't turn the body
don't lift the jaw off the ground
the hand must come to the end
of the body
if it's short you're
you're holding back what you should be
delivering
i
think of a motorbike throttle
and block
i think for motorbike throttle and block
these are the stages but this is still
part of the same number
of two so this is where it's confusing
because the carter
you would do it this way
okay and three
motorbike throttle in the other hand
turn it over
press theirs down
and away from you down and away from you
down and away from you
if you don't press it away from you
and you come over the top you'll be
hooking their joe
so that they can get you so you need to
open their body up this is what's
happening to their body
if you press it away from you
there here it opens them to there
they have to retake the ski
opens their body they have to retake
the ski and while they're retaking
while they're retaking
you will ski them
so it becomes one
me son
she
you finish this person you've hit them
in the heart
and you've stopped the rhythm of their
heart the electricity will stop that's
all you're doing you're hitting them
the thump on the chest it throws the
heart out
go to the middle of your joe turn all
the way down
into hassan you end in this position
and you change to this position so it's
all
all done as one this would be the suburi
thing
open the front foot
[Music]
so
from this position number seven
since he used to really shout i said we
didn't do it
you must as if you've been surprised
look over your left shoulder
start turning the hips don't
turn as one use the power of your hips
[Music]
turn your head your hips
nail the foot
head hips foot
now the joe come
come under over
so
when it goes to the ski think of it like
a snake's tongue
in out
what i do it's up to you you don't have
to do what i do
but this this is what i found works for
me now when i
bring it back i open the front foot
some people will like it something well
it's so that i don't have to now open it
when i come back for the get engaged
okay let's get in guys but in the 13 joe
carter
it's a high parry so you get this
feeling
it's just it's the other way up
so i like this movement because it's i i
time this with my hips the way my hips
my pelvis tip weight my pelvis tips
um you've got to have more than just
your arms
strength you've got to have timing and
muscular
physical ligaments tendons fascia
everything
working as well if you want to find coke
you
super human power you might call it it's
not super human
it's all of you it's what's making you
one as one
this is striking their joe away
again it's to open up so you get enough
time to come in here
if you strike it down again you're gonna
get stuck
and you're gonna have to come up to ski
i'll do it in slow motion
uh
so
you'll notice that my feet float around
a lot
that's what i've now arrived at
at my level other people will work
perhaps differently
it doesn't matter what teacher you watch
they'll all be different
but they're all doing like you know
they're doing their iq
not your like you know not mike you know
but you gain
pieces from each teacher that you see
that you like
i'll try that i'll try that you've got
to try it long enough to see if you like
it or not
but in time you will know
so
okay so we've got two
the garden
pressing it away i mean it's a it's a
powerful hit
you know you're knocking it away you're
now
coming here high and driving down into
their heart area
the center of their chest note it's the
height of my
joe the sensor used to get really mad
because a lot of people used to
would try to slightly tell if you if
they hit your joe
at any time that it's going to hit your
temple
and you're going to be the one that's
out of action not not them
so you must make this
high high to the center of their chest
it comes out about the center of my own
chest because i don't have a partner so
i have to put a target somewhere so i
work
on my own
see how i hit the window even
cytoscencey
said oh sensei made mistakes so there
you go you've got a small
mistake for me
um
go look
[Music]
they come to thrust at your side
you knock it away remember don't knock
it down
knock it away so you might have to lower
your body here
they're going to come here from the
kidneys so
it's no good doing hitting it from your
standard height
which is going to hook under there and
you'll be to the disadvantage
lower the body
okay strike it away
heart strike it away
ski and finish remember the hand
comes faster body
should fit your wrist there
pitch knee
sound
[Music]
you can copy my footwork if you want but
in the end
if your body is flowing
it will all work together
okay that's uh all the detail i
wish to give you today hope you enjoy
it and i hope it's a benefit and we'll
then move on to the next carter
thank you